[Music]
for as long as there's been competitive
counter-strike
there's been great leaders they're the
quarterbacks of the game
the ones who carry the burden of
deciding its cadence and the ones tasked
with solving its mysteries
while elevating those around them is
bolts coming through the vent jumping
down in fact in the middle of the side
has fallen
what kind of maniac play is this and
seeing the shoulder taking down kevin
they didn't see it coming and falling
turning around miraculous play in a game
so flush with star
power it's easy for your mind to wander
to the likes of simple
olaf meister or device but when it comes
down to the steps the best players in
the world take
the positions they hold and the tactics
they rely on
look at this position from jw though
this is god tier how the hell has he
gotten here
might be a freak out glad no no he
surely does it how has he read that
clave you are a master it's the in-game
leaders who so often called the shots
it's actually turned back olofmeister
gets that kill it's all down to kerrigan
so they've got to walk in and try and
get this bomb planet before he arrives
he does get crims
but they're going to hold the bomb plant
but he actually catches on
kerrigan he's gonna win it for tsm
they're the linchpins of professional
counter-strike the brains
behind the brawn and this is their story
[Music]
igls and the conversations that surround
them in their role
are the sort of cryptic underbelly of
counter-strike
equivalent to something like pro
baseball sabermetrics they're
infinitely important and at the core of
every successful team
but when you're watching the action it
won't be them that will draw your eye
they're the architects of their game
virtuosos of positioning
executes and strategy the focus of
analyst eyes from the likes of thorin
sponge or yanko
every igl colors the role with their own
brush
from the anti-striding style of sean
guerrez to kerrigan's roster
building prowess from motivational
leaders like taz
to ones who call while fragging with the
best like fallen
from pronax to blade golden to stanislaw
every igl does things a little
differently
throughout counter-strike's history you
can track the trajectory
of its most celebrated teams through the
minds of some of the game's most
heralded
igls and that's where we're going to
take you
back to the very beginning where what is
arguably the game's most important
position
was first defined
the in-game leader position has more or
less been under construction
since the days of counter-strike 1.6 at
its very core
a team's in-game leader has a number of
responsibilities
firstly they have to manage the talent
around them and create a system that
best utilizes each player's unique skill
set
they're tasked with calling strats at
the start of a round reacting to changes
in play on the fly
and generally getting their team from
point a to point b
igls are leaned on to adjust positioning
in-game when something just
isn't working it's hard to start any
discussion about 1.6
without uttering the name fanatic they
won
everything and redefined the way the
game was played at the highest level
both with their awe-inspiring mechanics
and their incredible ability
to work as a team 11 seconds they can't
even afford to engage in a fight here
they have to plant
oh that was brilliantly worked again by
fanatica
again they start off slow but when they
push back out
they just sat there oh okay max you can
play slow just
you have to come to us anyway and
leading that team was patrick karn
saderman now karn wasn't the flashiest
player on the server
but he was a lot of the brains behind
the most dominant team's brawn
and i've always been a team player even
in in my real life like
sports soccer and you know all those
kind of things and
somehow cs came into the picture i think
this was in 99 and
one of my best friends in sweden
downloaded the the half-life mod
and i just got caught really i just
played many may look back on that fnatic
team as helping elevate cs
to a new level but what was truly
special about them was how they played
as
one strategically they were unmatched
and at the center of that
was one igl and that format that
followed the leader composition
would become a fixture in cs of course
while karn and fnatic were making a name
for themselves during 1.6 a player by
the name of daniel
zeus teslanko was also beginning his
storied igl career with madison sayre
and also they get a check over 50
000 us dollar prize money ladies and
gentlemen please give me again an
applause
for the best team of the internet
extreme master season 4 counter strike
1.6
[Music]
the ukrainian organization where the
perennials second fiddle to fnatic
during their heralded 1.6 dominance they
didn't have the same level of talent
that their greatest rivals possessed
but many revered zeus as a mastermind
and a key to the team's success
then we have zeus of course team captain
and the strat caller
for navi and again he really really
stepped up his game i can't really
say that enough times when it comes to
these two lineups whereas karn was
celebrated for his ability to wrangle
together the best players in the game
zeus specialized at working with what he
had and turned na'vi
into a counter-strike powerhouse if
they're gonna win this title
they'll have to go through the best team
in the world that's how you want a
world championship to be set up early on
in the game's competitive legacy
names like zeus and karn created the
framework for what we now know
as a full-time day-in day-out position
within the game's competitive landscape
but what that position has proven to be
is an ever-changing puzzle
during the beginning of cs go's
competitive development new name stepped
up to take the reins as defining igls in
a brand new game
and it was these players that ended up
defining the rosters they played on
and became some of the most influential
players in cs go's early days
kevin existence julones was one of the
game's first great analytical minds
and was the leading voice behind the
famed ldlc lineup
that would eventually become g2 esports
he's often looked at for his ability to
redefine his role as an igl
while also managing talented players
like kenny s and shocks
t-side has often been considered the
more strategy intensive of the two roles
in cs
and existence will always be remembered
for what he did to further teesside
strategy
with impressive shot calling planting
positioning and leadership
his teams that played under him played
fantastic
cs go very enjoyable to watch tactically
sound you can understand the logic of
what they were doing on certain maps the
way they responded to things
the execution was a very very high level
fantastic to watch very aesthetically
pleasing and intellectually stimulating
he was a model professional this is a
guy who's very polite
he doesn't make excuses when he loses
while existing strategic mind was
shining with that ldlc roster
richard exists landstrom was also
contributing to the rule's illustrious
history on ninjas and pajamas
exist is probably one of the like the
stable the most stable player in our
team
um i think he's like the core player if
you might
say so like he's the one that holds the
positions
he's making calls as t as the in-game
leader
and i mean he always gets his frags when
they're pushing onto his side so he's
also like one of the players that you
really want on your team
during the early days of cs go nip were
one of the most dominant teams in the
game
they were a lethal but more importantly
perfectly coordinated
fragging machine going in here for the
kill this is either very good of
everybody he's taken out
n.i.p gaming has started ladies and
gentlemen
they threw a hail mary wow came in with
a defuse
and that is probably the most insane
comeback of 2013 so far in cs go
exists proved to be a special kind of
in-game for his ability to frag at a
high level
while simultaneously leading his team
something that has proven particularly
difficult
in any era of the game exist the
current in-game leader of ninjas and
pajamas is a player where for
cs gold fans just for more modern day
fans it's going to be quite difficult to
actually understand the full context of
his career because where he is now the
the role he plays now his level of
success his status as a player is very
very different from where he was for the
majority of his career actually in cs
1.6
notably nip were known for shuffling the
igl duties around their roster
during that era but exist was often
looked at as the team's primary leader
and his ability to balance that role
with his lethal aim
puts him amongst the best igls to ever
play
and of course we can't forget about
kerrigan the danish igl is known as one
of the greatest roster builders of all
time
and his leadership has helped lead
fanatic astralis
and faze clan to world class success all
being
being a good indian leader for a top
team is is really important because
we have seen a phase without in-game
media they can't do a player playoffs
before i joined and right after we
joined we did playoffs and semi-finals
and finals so
i think that shows that you can't just
have five superstars players and nobody
really take the leading role so
when valve unveiled counter-strike
global offensive in 2012
it came complete with an in-game
spectator client that was specifically
designed for coaches
and while it seemed like a nice quality
of life upgrade for the teams
this little change would completely
alter the in-game leadership role
throughout the scene as great leaders
like exist and existence
were iterating on the role organizations
were increasingly starting to use this
new tool to better their in-game
communication
coaches would not only watch the games
but shot call as well
in an effort to take some of the weight
off the shoulders of their igls
obviously very happy for the boys
winning against eibar power on
cobblestone so yeah i'm a happy happy
coach
this was arguably best exemplified by
natus vincere's coach
sergey starrix is chuck in august 2016
navi released zeus their longtime
in-game leader and one of their founding
members
for a young superstar with jaw-dropping
aim and mechanical skill
and the desperate play in 2b comes in
smokes
you see a double smokes in the same
place there simple just jumping casually
into the side he's going to fall down
and get right down
right what is this simple are you
serious what is that you're going
through that simple
this move symbolized a major shift in
the in-game leader role
navi were forgoing a player igl for
superstar power
and moving the brunt of the leadership
responsibility to their coach
starix and they weren't the only ones to
do this during that same time frame
cloud9 replaced slemmy for automatic
and nip were being completely rebuilt
around their coach threat
i think we differ from other teams where
i don't like to have a player being the
opera or the lurker or anything i just
like to put
players in positions where i think they
will perform well
these organizations made a statement
that had been lingering on the minds of
analysts for weeks
you didn't need an igl when you could
just load your roster with star power
and put shot calling on the coaching
staff's shoulders
like i understand why they're saying
that and i can get
but behind it because i think if the
game wants to get to a point where a
coach
is the in-game leader and he does all of
the stuff that i just listed and more
he in-game leads he is the heart and
soul of the team
he's the captain of the team he does the
interview duties he
does the strategies he uh does the
mid-round calling he manages the money
he does all of that [ __ ] right he
literally is an in-game leader who does
not have to shoot
anybody ahead if every single team was
like that
that would be fantastic because what
you'd have is you have five players in
the server who are all fantastic at
their roles and jobs of fragging [ __ ]
and that's what their job would be and
in the short term navi
were right they're on the defuse it's a
championship inside smoke
but in the long term valve would make a
change that would shake the framework of
competitive counter-strike
they banned coaches from taking on the
igl role
valve had made the move prior to navi's
win at esl one new york 2016
but the effects of losing staric's
in-game role had yet to make an impact
on the team
but as time passed the community felt
betrayed by the position valve put them
in
teams had spent months building their
rosters around their coaches
and in one fell swoop valve completely
changed the way the competitive scene
worked
and the reaction wasn't exactly positive
the thing that kind of confuses me and
the reason like
it kind of sucks that they did this now
is that over the last year
people have been getting used to coaches
and developing coaches
and there hasn't been like aside from a
couple like conversations on the side
from valve at these majors they haven't
really said hey guys get ready to like
only have
your five it's a five player team
basically that we're talking about and
then you have a sixth man a coach and
valve felt like
the sixth man was becoming too much of a
player because some teams were using him
as an in-game leader
instead of just having him as a
cheerleader or a manager or even a coach
but you know a coach that's only
involved in
pauses etc after their win in new york
na'vi
just weren't the same team the complete
collapse of a world class team here
guardian gonna be going down and will be
sk
getting out of group c here defeating
now the on train
16 16-8 and they want on dust2 as well
sure they possess the single most
talented player the game had ever seen
but without star x or zeus in the
picture they just weren't the super
power
they look like they could be in new york
and while the ukrainian organization's
lack of leadership ended their run at
the pgl krakow major prior to the top
eight
a familiar face was making a cinderella
run
hobbits sitting there in connector a
dangerous position
device knows to look out for it misses
the flick shot
and garmin have done the unthinkable
they will be
in the major finals after leaving na'vi
zeus joined russian or
gambit esports who were building toward
a run at the pgl krakow major
they brought in zeus in the hopes of
adding some veteran leadership to their
roster
and what happened next shocked the cs go
world
that have done it
an unlikely final but worthy of every
round
what a performance from all 10 players
everyone
had their moments gambit weren't the
most talented team in the world
but on that day at that tournament they
were the best
and that's what leadership means i just
say
all of maester i love you
and second god help me
and i won't measure
[Applause]
the impact of the coaching ban in the
preceding shuffling of rosters and roles
was one of the major stories in cs go
throughout 2016.
the way organizations were looking to
assemble talent was changing
and it all ventured around the igl
position
we saw faze clan choose one of those
extremes over the course of 2017
when they assembled what was possibly
the most star-studded roster
in cs history under the gaze of
legendary igl
kerrigan robin has said we've been
looking for a long time for
for a guy who could lead the team inside
the server instead of
lead as a coach because that is that is
hard to be an example and leading
as a coach compared to in-game and
showing how it needs to be done
but even with kerrigan and after
adapting to the impact of the coaching
ban
faze has only shown flashes of
brilliance reign
arsenal toward the firebox and hope of a
kill all in in one position and guardian
makes it just nicer to find the flash
and nikko fittingly gets the last kill
his face dominate new york in 2017 in
the barclays center all the way through
this tournament
these days while we're watching the
various in-game leader situations across
the best teams in the world
from phase to natas vincere to fallen
and mibr
one thing is consistent
[Music]
and now for the astralis time ever at
home season eight i've strolled into the
champions of esl pro league and for the
first time in history
the best of all [ __ ] time until grand
slam
it destroys there's no question that
we're in the era of astralis
during the 2018 and 2019 cs go seasons
we've watched as they've proven time and
time again to be one of the best teams
in cs history
well it's finally happened james i think
i think this error might last for a very
long time
all right lorna let's hear it for
astralis
nobody can touch these guys they are not
on another level
they are on another planet there's been
a lot made about what makes astralis so
good but at the center of every
conversation
is lucas glaive roseander if if the team
is playing good tactically
that is when they shine that is when
they show consistency
that is when their star players is
starting to rise so i think
the igl and and the team play and the
communication and
the things that igl understands and
makes his players do
is one of the most important things in
the game the danish team's in-game
leader has crafted the unbelievable
depth of map pool and strategic
dominance that the team has become
widely known for
it was the addition of glaive in place
of kerrigan that jump-started the
astralis team
we know now so what changed about
astralis when they got glaive into the
lineup as the in-game leader
is this was someone who not only could
harness
the players in his team he's always some
of the best players
not only could develop a good offensive
side a good ct set
not only could do all the basics but the
key element
was he brought the final piece of the
philosophy that has allowed the team to
have this level of success they've had
and while doing so he's done what few
have ever achieved
fragging at the level of the rest of his
team while leading them
they've all been neutralized just by the
flames but that's a good entry but
they're all so low
and glade's gonna get another one and
he's gonna finish it off after the
community was sent reeling in the wake
of the coaching ban
astralis has taught us a lot about what
it takes to be among the best in
counter-strike
many of the world's biggest names were
brought together but it was the danish
cohorts that were able to surpass the
competition
by playing the kind of counter-strike
that's only possible with
absolutely perfect teamwork leadership
and execution
if you look at zonic and glaive what he
can bring strategically what he can
bring motivational that relationship has
really allowed that team to kind of
skyrocket
and eventually that pairing team and
coach understanding of what their role
is and being defined
is going to lead to new strides
within the confines of just this one
position we're told a story of
professional counter-strike
of the early days of solving puzzles to
the refined machine of modern esports
and one wrench in the plans that turned
the cs world
on its head but inside the world of the
in-game leader
we see the beauty of esports what's
beneath the surface of quickly ending
rounds spray patterns and crosshairs
the hours spent face to face behind the
scenes
player to player and coach to coach
solving the
game trying to break it like astralis on
nuke
or old fanatic on inferno there is no
dominance
without leadership
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button